whatever we do we can be creative and
that's what I really enjoy doing sitting
around the table batting ideas around
with people and then you have a flash of
insight wow we've got to try this it has
to be consistent it has to be
self-consistent mathematically it has to
be consistent with all the data that are
out there and if you violate any one of
those things so if you make a big
mistake and you put that out in public
you could really hurt your career too I
think I'm known for having a lot of
ideas and I'm very careful most of them
die within 10 minutes or maybe within a
week but having them stick around for 30
years that's pretty cool I remember in
grad school one of my professors saying
if you have a paper that's still quoted
10 years later you're doing well so I
guess that's the standard that I live by
and so I'm doing pretty well